[Music]
we are learning harrowing new details
this morning about how 12 missionaries
say they were able to escape from armed
captors in haiti last week the
missionaries worked for the ohio-based
christian aid ministry and a
spokesperson for the group says eight
adults with four children slipped by
their captors wednesday night and began
to make their way over difficult terrain
after a number of hours of walking
day began to dawn and they eventually
found someone who helped them make a
phone call for help
they were finally free
the group was among the 17 people
abducted by the gang way back in october
five others had already been released
christian aid ministries confirms that
ransom money had been raised but they
would not say if the money played any
role in last week's escape sounds like
they just slipped out i want to know all
the details of this i heard that they
broke down a door there's all sorts of
conflicting things but the bottom line
is they're free and they're out with
little children and babies yeah can you
imagine that moment where they made the
decision we have to we have to make a
run for it yeah that sounds like a movie
and maybe it will be one one day